you two are always compare because of
the draft day trade and the reality is
when you take a step back you're very
close in points I think you probably
lead an assist yeah I'm for sure but the
narrative out there isn't the same talk
to me about that I don't even stress
over here no more like I just I know the
real ones get it I feel like for me once
I win a championship they'll even open
up more more eyes to what I've really
done especially to some of my peers that
I'm compared with to be honest with you
I have no hate towards nobody especially
Luca we talk all the time we got a lot
of love for each other a lot of respect
for each other there's different agendas
and different and the way people look at
certain people is is different to be
honest I don't get caught up into it I
feel like eventually people are going to
understand what it is and realize that
it's not that far off we kind of do the
same things we're different in size but
I mean he can play like I can play you
know what I'm saying we can we can both
hoop so at the same time that's just
what it is